crying death it's going to be it's going
to be tough
it'll be emotional and I know it's two
words but action-packed strategic Jared
Padalecki and Jensen Ackles dishin on
the final season of Supernatural try and
do the show justice you know try and do
these characters some some justice and
honor the legacy that was supernatural
and other writers and the directors and
actors and actresses and producers and
our network and our studio and just try
and try and do well by the fandom you
know Jared said it best I don't think
we'll ever say goodbye to these
characters I mean I really lived with
them for 15 years is only the start you
know this is who was it I think I think
it was Stallone that said that to the to
the greatest imaginary friend I've ever
had talking about Rocky Balboa and I
kind of feel the same way
you know this these guys will these guys
will live with us for forever you don't
you dare think that there is anything
past or present that I would put in
front of you the guys also went down
memory lane talking about their early
days on the show it was almost 15 years
ago it's my first childhood memory
actually being I'm sad basically
essentially I remember just
the feeling of infinite possibilities
you know I thought we might go for a
full season you know yeah maybe we'll
know maybe we'll go for season two yeah
it was you know at that at that point he
and I were just really excited to be a
part of a show and to to be kind of
captaining that show and you know we
didn't want to mess it up and it was
also right during the whole merge of the
network so there was a lot of change
over there was a lot of disruption going
on and we weren't sure what the fate of
our show was so I think the fact that we
went somehow managed to weather that
storm and get through the other side was
a big testament kind of what we had and
then it was just not trying not to mess
it up for the next 14 years we don't
know ya know we you know I don't think I
think to a certain degree that fandom
won't be happy with any ending nor will
we to certain degree I don't think any
of us want to see this show go but back
to your earlier question it's about
doing it proper justice and here's what
they plan on stealing from set I've said
it before for me it's all about the car
yeah it's been such a heavy part of the
character and a heavy part of the show
somebody Salim Khan what would you do
murder I'd murder them all there's
little knickknacks little little
mementos that probably won't mean
anything to anybody else but probably
but means something to me when when we
burned down Bobby's house there was an
owl paperweight on the fireplace and I
remember before we were gonna use the
set for the last time I was like nope
this is mine now
I still happen yeah our set deck
Department just realized where that went
and they're like damn it Jerry the legal
team at Warner but right now see Cindy
says I remember like yeah little
knickknacks like the season finale of
the I'm sorry
yeah season tally up season one Sam's
driving the Impala and I figured again
we didn't over getting backed up [ __ ]
car was getting destroyed so there's the
scene where I'm sitting there and I was
like you know what I'm gonna take this I
took a little Impala decal out of that
first car so I still have that but
little stuff but no one whatever you
know it means something to me